have you heard for teach for america no
okay so teach for america
i don't even know if it's a non-profit
or if it's a foundation
like political activist group but
essentially what they do is
they try to reverse um teaching and
education disparities in
lower income neighborhoods by
essentially taking gifted
college students who may be a little bit
directionless
like you know they don't have a lot of
direction where they're going into
basically taking on a one to two year
teaching assignment on an accelerated
teaching credential
in hard-hit cities like chicago detroit
los angeles
et cetera and they do a few great things
for you
i'm not before i disparage them they
they help pay back your student loans
while you're there
that's great they give you a stipend
they give you a salary and they give you
something to do for a couple of years
while you don't know what you're doing
with a
proper salary with medical so it's not a
bad organization and
and it's very prestigious actually it's
kind of hard to get accepted
um because of the fact there's so many
college students who are directionless
like they don't have any uh they don't
like all of them basically so it's like
everyone graduates hold on
you got a degree in microbial molecular
biology yeah yeah and you're a
journalist
yeah i actually dropped out of grad
school to do this wow yeah
so you're not going to be a scientist
you're letting down you're signing
you're i still get messages from med
school saying please come to our school
i did really well too
people don't realize this i didn't like
i almost got a 4.0
in in in molecular biology i did
extremely well in my advanced courses
did research uh
i worked on projects for immunotherapy i
i'm like believe it or not
i know like my show it's so funny like i
purposely am just trying to be
very relaxed and normal like i am in
real life but when it comes to
the books and math and things some of us
still do maths you know well so so
what's up with this program you're
talking about yeah yeah so so so i
i i applied to it because um i missed
some of the application dates for some
of my grad schools and i was gonna just
take a year off and i was like
no i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna go do
this program and um
i had to go to the training before we
started school i got my credential i did
all the tests and blah blah blah
constitution training and i got i passed
everything first time and i'm ready to
go
and then i have to go to this training
in los angeles and
the first thing they made us do was to
split off into groups of
of being the oppressed or the oppressor
what
now i want to tell you this i i think
i think i was the only
might have been the only white male
there
but but there was a group of people i'm
not even going to use heterosexual or
anything but it was basically just like
said if you like women and you're a man
or you're a woman and you like men
go to this group et cetera it was weird
that we're talking about our our
our intimate life um at a teacher's
thing
like i'm thinking like i'm not i'm not
about you but when i'm in a room with
strangers i'm not interested in
what's going on there yeah you know what
you know what all of this is it's an
exercise
in independent function of an individual
if you go into a building and they say
we are going to here here's a job
and we are going to negatively impact
your life and your salary and your job
if you fit certain criteria
and all you have to do is be like oh
yeah i'm gay sure whatever
and then they leave you alone well not
for for milo he didn't get away with
that but i was gonna say like
you know what was weird is by the end of
this i was the only person in my own a
group i was the
ultimate oppressor and i remember
they're like does anyone have any
negative thoughts about this and i said
yes
i have thoughts about this what does
this have to do with teaching
high school students about cellular
function all i need to tell them is the
mitochondria is the powerhouse of the
cell
and tell and tell juan to get his get it
stop looking at inappropriate images
during class on his phone and
you know like i mean that's i understand
most of it's just just class management
but but but when it gets down to it i
was realizing they were even talking
about how there's certain
words you can't use you're not in
control of the class you're managing the
class
like there's all this weird sjw stuff
and i even hate that word so 2017
but but it's true this was during that
era so i can use that 2016 era or
whatever and
and i sat there and i go something is
wrong with this country
where i've come in to teach kids science
which is very indiscriminate in fact
for a lot of a lot of time besides
people think there's all these debates
and evolution everything
not in real science science everyone
just goes whatever evolution you
disagree agree
let's go do research let's go let's go
study cell development let's go study
pathways and try to figure out new
interferons et cetera and develop
immunological therapies no one's like
hey dude who who do you
who do you sleep with like no one ever
asks well hold on
be fair i think if i'm gonna understand
what the mitochondria is i need to know
if you're banging dudes
down there but like i i mean like i'm
just thinking like i'm going i remember
staying there and i i
called npr and i and i talked to i think
it was larry elder
and i remember that's kind of how i got
started elder really one of the people
is that is that that's his name
is that npr he might have been at one
point maybe maybe i have the wrong
person
i could be i could be wrong you could
look that up but it was one of the big
guys and he took me on and i complained
about it publicly and said
i i cannot this was during the time of
outrage where people were start just
starting to wake up and i'm going
i cannot believe i'm trying to get into
science and be a professor and go in
this direction
and i'm being asked about who i sleep
with i'm being ostracized
because of the color of my skin i'm in
this program because i did well
i'm in this program not like boasting
but i'm here because i have high marks
because because i i i'm overqualified
i'm here
i'm a blessing to this program not being
prideful but meaning
i'm i'm actually looking at this not the
program like you know what i would love
for a year to invest in some high school
kids lives junior high kids lives pour
into them teach them about life science
help them get into some good colleges
but no i end up quitting the program
because they demonized me over a weekend
experience
literally and then here's the best part
at the end they had this weird
you know these really weird exercises
that they do like these weird like group
have you have you been a part of any of
these no i you know look i i didn't go
to high school
okay you really i didn't go to high
school at all do you ever have a ged no
good hey hell yeah that's that
dude i was i was a teenage anarchist
after system
i don't play by your rules i do what i
want when i want that was it
can we talk about the black cloud people
here can i mention that my name is that
okay i know
hey guys if you're watching this and
you're tearing down your city burning it
down
just so you know you can become a
successful youtuber just like
tim that was just my psa to that oh yeah
well they're not burning down their own
cities
oh yeah they're burning down other
people's cities right no okay we'll get
to that i was gonna say
so they had this weird me to ask
exercise where
we we had two separate groups split up
and one group got in a circle and we
closed
our eyes and they had you they had the
other group walk around the circle and
touch on the shoulder
um people who they agreed met this
question so they'd ask something like
who changed your experience this weekend
and people would walk up and touch the
person with their eyes closed shoulder
very creepy yeah
you know what you know what i would do
and this is probably this is part of the
reason why i didn't end up going to high
school
is because i challenged authority no
matter what and i played up i
prayed upon their assumptions i was 14.
if they did an exercise where they were
like
this you know that was your eyes and let
strangers touch you you know what i
would do
i would i would i would start making
noises and go i don't like to be
touched and i just i like i
i have stories of when i so i went to
high school for about two months
and then ultimately they were like this
kid can't be here it's like freshman
year 14.
yeah yeah yeah so i was interesting they
they they realized i could not be in the
school
because all of the loopholes all of the
all of the the cracks in the system oh i
found all of them
and i prayed upon every assumption
everything they did
so that they could not actually like i i
found predicaments to put them in where
they were like what do we do
like the rules don't apply like what it
was there's just funny circumstances
where they would try and challenge me on
things and then finally one teacher just
told me to f off and like gave me an
effort
it's a long story but i tried i tried uh
praying upon the assumptions of one of
the assignments
by creating a circumstance in which he
couldn't call me a liar
and then ultimately he just took a blank
sheet of paper and put an effort
that was essentially what happened it's
a longer story but see i i like that
that that actually so i've gotten
expelled from i got expelled from high
school
and then i almost got expelled the
second time so i'm proud of you for not
even going
because it was kind of not worth it the
only thing i like i i wish i had those
kind of
cajones or whatever when i was in uh
high school but i do know that i did
when i was about to get expelled for the
second time for my second high school
they
asked me why i crossed the line and
similarly i said
i didn't cross the line i was smart
enough to bend down and see that it was
flexible wire and i grabbed and i
stretched it further past
anyone had ever gone but i'm still on
the other side oh my gosh yeah yeah yeah
anyway anyway it looks like i bring this
up to make the point yeah
a lot of people i know went to school
got that indoctrination or at least a
little bit of it as it was drones
as it was creeping in and so i remember
uh the reason i didn't go to college
specifically was that i read
an article from an economist who said if
you go to any investor
and say for forty thousand dollars over
four years you will owe forty thousand
dollars plus interest they'll laugh in
your face
and so i was like wow that doesn't seem
to make sense college seems to be a
waste of time
that's why i was like i'm not going to
do it i'm not going to take on debt for
this nebulous concept guess how much i
have left debt
oh what do you got 92 000 left congrat
good luck oh yeah well like
you know what though luckily we're in
we're in uh covid so
it's currently frozen frozen but but i
will say i'll pay that off pretty soon
but i but i'm just gonna say at the end
of all this when people asked when at
the end they had a question of whose
opinion like changed your mind the most
about the world this weekend which is
weird we have a week in training
a lot of people meet me in that moment
you know me
i mean they touched me while my eyes are
they touch you and i don't mean that it
wasn't like a glory moment it was
actually a pathetic moment where i was
going
oh my gosh these are college educated
people who probably come from decent
universities you have to have a certain
grade cut off et cetera
and i did nothing but slightly brought
up
a little dissension a little bit of
adversity to the mainstream opinion and
this
affected you this is not a good program
this is not helping people this is this
is this is just a weird
probably government-funded program that
i don't want to be a part of
and and i remember just thinking like
man
this is when i actually really woke up
to i'm going i don't want to be in the
system because the system is going in a
weird direction
i don't want to be a part of educating
people if educating people becomes
indoctrination
and i know that some people are like
well you know this sounds like
four-year-old talking points this was
literally
four years ago this is a four-year-old
talking point this is an important
primer for we're going into next yeah
i'm just saying like this is what
happened and this is what got me to like
okay i'm not doing that anymore and i
was lost for a little bit
until i realized what was the source of
the problem it's the culture wars
yeah so this is uh it's it's been
building up for a long time
the media plays a big role in it partly
because of i talked about this too i
actually had an argument with uh
peter pagosian are you familiar with
peter he's a professor associate
professor of philosophy i believe in
portland
is portland right i'm not sure how that
i know his name sounds similar
he's one of these so-called squared
hoaxers who uh tricked a bunch of
scientific journals into accepting
garbled mumbo jumbo
they rewrote a chapter from mineconf but
put in feminist buzzwords and it got
approved or something like that anyway
we were having a conversation before
about whether this started in the
universities or started with the media
and i think a lot of what he's saying is
true but i think
it only broke into the mainstream
because of social media algorithms
the general idea to simplify because i
talk about it quite kind of a lot is
if you make a video uh if you make a
video or article
youtube doesn't work so much this way
but on youtube on facebook if you make a
video about
police brutality it'll get a thousand
shares if you make a video about racism
a thousand shares if you get a video
about racist police brutality
it gets a thousand plus a thousand
shares so you know x plus y
so what ended up happening was companies
realized that what was making them the
most money was mashing
as many keywords as possible into an
article thus you get these ideas
becoming predominant you know very
mainstream in 2008 and
it was like 2006 when it started it was
i think it was 06 you know it was around
the facebook time when people were
finding out they could monetize the
facebook news feed
and then by like 2010 you can see all
the data in lexisnexis the hockey stick
of inclusivity and white fragility and
all these phrases are skyrocketing
because they realized
mixing keywords like there's an article
from vice where it's like black trans
women of color
fighting for black lives matter against
police brutalities proves the patriarchy
is real like
they just they jam it all in there
because what happens is the algorithm
shares it with more people and so that
leads to where we're at now
and i think one of the reasons it's it's
it really does in my opinion
describe your experience but i do think
the ideas had to exist first
so yes the universities but my opinion
on this is the media
because you take a look at what's going
on right now police brutality right
did you know that there was a period
where like the most shared videos on
facebook were all police brutality
i believe it i mean i mean even watching
like cops and stuff people always loved
it when the police got down with the
suspects
i think i think the reason for it is
that anger is the principal motivator
for
sharing it's the it's the it's the most
prominent motivator so people get mad
they share things
when people are happy or inspired they
share them a lot less people are sad
they definitely don't share
so anger is the number one emotion that
drives
content sharing so you make a video
about you know police brutality
people get angry about it and they share
it this is not okay
and that drives the narrative we have
today which is skewed
and then the mainstream media who's been
just
eating the refuse of the facebook
algorithm for a decade
are sitting there in the newsroom
believing all of this garbage is real
life
you look at don lemon's opinion from
several years ago remember
when he said he was talking about uh he
was talking about ferguson i think or no
no wasn't ferguson he was talking about
like black lives matter
and about how they have to pull their
pants up or something yeah and don lemon
made a bunch of racist stereotypes about
black people
on cnn live and his opinion's completely
inverted today
because it's only getting worse and
worse and worse then when ends up
happening is
you're talking about this college stuff
and i'm reminded of that viral video you
ever see it where the guy
goes but you're a white male remember
that sounds like 4 500
videos i've seen it's the famous meme
where the guy's got like really greasy
long black hair
and he's watching guy yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
awful can we bring that up can you bring
up a picture of that lydia or something
can i see this person i i can show it to
you after the fact
anyway there's like a a conflict at a
college and he yells but you're a white
male
effing a white male yeah you're an
effing white male and there's like a
bunch of moments like that
and that's where this fractured ideology
was emboldened empowered by these
algorithms broke into the mainstream
we talked about a few years ago like oh
these dang old college kids acting all
crazy huh now they're
in positions in government and now
they're
they are the real world yeah now they're
in their 30s and they're running
non-profits and they're infecting
so you're so this is the first i'm
hearing of the fact that
you know because obviously you pre-date
me by like just a couple years but still
you've been in this game and you've been
run now you're running it you you're
like this is pretty crazy
you're saying that the algorithms are
almost what drove
the intersectional push which is kind of
in line with the scriptures the bible
scripture
says not that money is the root of all
evil but the love
of money is at the root of all evil
which probably transcends multiple
cultures
but i believe the bible's authoritative
and that source in in that
you're saying that this is this is like
basically very important
i'll tell you they love money so then
they bring us this doctrine this
doctrine moves in
it brings more money so all at the
source of this is somebody saying we're
going to get rich off of effing over the
entire country let alone the whole world
they they don't look at it that way i
think a lot of these people are ignorant
some of them know what they're doing
there's a prominent site that collapsed
recently
in the past year so when they started
they were a libertarian pro ron paul
website
because that was really popular on the
internet and then they realized
when so it's it's not like some dude
singing in a room and he goes
here's a map of the algorithm here's
what we're going to do we're going to
promote this stuff to make money what
happens is
they hire 10 people one guy writes
intersectional stuff one guy writes
police brutality one guy writes about
science and then all of a sudden they
start realizing intersectionality
does the best not they're not they're
not looking at this person being like
okay intersectionality articles are
doing great what happens is they say
have you seen john's articles they're
getting like a million views it's great
let's let's let's have him get a team
together and hire some people
john an sjw then hires more saws make a
unit that unit starts getting way more
traffic and way more views
and many of these companies did not
actually realize what was happening
some of them did and tried to capitalize
on it and it didn't work
because they they tried telling people
we want you to write this and the people
would be like i'm not writing that
garbage
and then it wouldn't work the companies
that worked naturally just hired those
who got the traffic
and this created a big bubble of
empowered media personalities
who were woke far left and now many of
them have moved up in these companies
and now they're 30
or you know 34 or whatever and now
they're hiring young people who
agree with them and now the new york
times they were raised on their milk
basically you know and that's but that's
what i'm seeing it you know and
the really interesting thing is about
this whole intersectional push and this
weird
dogma is how quickly it's become
mainstream which is really interesting
because
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you